hi rich burnett here for a look inside
current events with
the great courses today i'm chatting
with connell fullen camp
about what we've learned from the
gamestop short and how these events
might change the future
of online trading hi connell hi it's
nice to be here
so you did an awesome job explaining the
gamestop situation in a series of
articles that were running on the great
courses daily i'll
put a link to them up here somewhere
but could you take a moment just to
explain the situation here before we get
started
yeah so so the the the game stop uh
phenomenon was really a bunch of small
individual investors who are trying to
put on what is called a short squeeze
on the uh the hedge funds who are trying
to sell the shares short
so they're driving the price up hopeful
hoping that these hedge funds would have
to buy back the shares at an even higher
price
and and they got kind of a monkey wrench
thrown in the works last week
when uh basically what happened was the
the financial plumbing
that they did they relied on to buy and
sell the shares got gummed up
and so robin hood uh the broker that the
the traders were using
had to actually restrict the the the
purchases and sales of shares
on its platform because it had run afoul
of the rules
of basically the the clearing and
settlement system that that that
actually trades the shares
so what's the actual term for what the
robin hood app
is so so robin hood basically is a
broker
they're they're basically a commission
free broker so between the hedge funds
and robin hood and their clearinghouse
and the reddit community
um wall street bets have any of these
players acted unethically
from my perspective no i i think we see
um
people certainly disagreeing over and
certainly vehemently disagreeing over
the value of a company and the value of
shares um
but but i don't see anybody really
acting unethically here and like i said
the
the thing that really stopped the
trading was pure kind of risk management
on the part of the clearing and
settlement system
and i think that's one part of the story
that people don't quite understand and
it raises questions clearly
if you don't understand how the system
works then you can always think that
there are possibilities for
for bad actors or or people acting in
bad faith but i really don't see that
here i see this is
as basically people learning the hard
way
how the system actually really works so
robin hood's clearing house required
them to limit the trading of stocks but
what does a clearinghouse actually do
yeah sure so underlying the the trading
that we do
on the exchanges or really of any kind
of assets
we actually have to have um somebody
really literally moving the money and
moving the shares back and forth
and the institutions that do that are
these these clearing houses
and and the clearinghouses are the
places where brokers like robin hood
they have to open an account
that allows them to participate in the
system and actually move the money and
shares around
and of course what what these clearing
systems are worried about
is the failure of somebody who has an
account there so
every time an organization wants to
trade shares
they have to actually open an account
and post collateral there
to make sure that if something bad
happens to this company
you know its customers can't pay or the
trades go wrong or something like that
that that the whole system doesn't
collapse so what happened here was
basically
when when robin hood started to put
through an a hugely in
increased volume of shares and since the
shares were all
on the buy side rather than being on
either side of the market
the clearinghouse basically it's a risk
management system was triggered and
naturally it said hey
you need to put more more funds in that
account to cover
the the vastly increased amount of
trading that you're doing
and robinhood didn't have the money
right then and there
so they had to do something to um they
had to do something to
make sure that they didn't exceed their
trading limits and so they actually had
to put limits on the individual traders
themselves
so why do we even need this middleman
this clearinghouse entity between
investors oh yeah yeah so it's really
fascinating right because in the old
days
um you would buy and sell physical
shares
and the shares would have to be moved
from one owner to the other and this
process could take
you know days and days so to speed up
trading we did two things number one
we converted all the paper shares of
stock to basically
you know electronic records uh in a
computer
and then we put a clearing house in
charge of maintaining those records
so basically what the clearinghouses do
is they they basically you know
they're the repository for all the
information who owns what and
um uh and who's buying what so
the clearinghouses really they they
actually make the trades happen it's
almost like they
are the um the underside of the exchange
right and the exchange people are
making bids and they're they're striking
deals but then somebody actually has to
like
change the book entries in the in the
computer and actually move the money
between the players and that's really
what the clearinghouses do
it's just it's as i keep calling it it's
financial plumbing it's a really
key part of the financial plumbing that
makes the that keeps the funds
and the assets moving back and forth so
it's really critical but we don't and we
and it's
and i like to call it plumbing because
just like the plumbing in your house you
ignore it until it goes haywire and then
it causes
all kinds of problems so do you think
the reddit community wall street vets
got
lucky uh with the situation or is this
something that's going to be easily
repeatable
well i i do think it's a repeatable
event but i think we have to be very
careful about
how it can be repeated so gamestop was
kind of
an out of the way unloved um not very
highly traded company
with not a ton of shares outstanding so
it was a relatively small company a
relatively small
fish in the pond so to speak and i think
in in situations like that
groups like the sub the individual
investors from the subreddit
can actually can actually make prices
move so in other words when you have a
thinly traded market that isn't very
liquid yeah it doesn't take as much
to move the price around so um there are
there are many stocks that are like that
on the exchanges that and that can
happen
so what do you think hedge funds are
going to do to keep from being
blindsided by something like this again
in the future
i think they're going to pay much more
attention to the to the ponds that
they're playing in i think that the
that the hedge funds got caught out they
just they were just kind of asleep at
the wheel
and and really not paying attention to
the small investors
thinking that they could you know make
these bats and not have to really worry
too much
about anything other than the kind of
the fundamentals of the company i mean
after all
you know gamestop did look like it was
in long-term decline the fundamentals
didn't look very good
and for a lot of these hedge funds this
looked like a pretty good short bet
um the the problem is that they
overlooked the the role of the
individual investors and i think
you know the individual investors
started to stoke the price
uh even in 2020 so i i i'm
i'm thinking that the hedge funds have
have learned a very expensive lesson
that you cannot
now in in some of these markets ignore
the individual investors
do you think there's a chance that hedge
funds might try adopting some of these
reddit
strategies to manipulate the price of
stocks to their own whims
yeah so when you when you get into the
the um
professional institutional investors
then the sec starts to get
starts to crack down really fast on that
type that that type of coordinated
activity so so the sec or the
securities exchange commission is our
main securities market regulator
so they they um they regulate not only
the issuance of securities but also the
trading of securities that regulate the
exchanges
and they regulate the companies that
make their business in trading and
brokering
securities so their their primary goal
of the sec
is to protect the individual investor
and so that's why they're really
they're really leery about a possible
collusion by big players
that would hurt small individual
investors and so they're trying to
promote
the rights and and consumer protection
for individual investors and
and they're trying to police some of the
bad practices
especially um uh bad practices that are
aimed at in
at individual investors so i i think
that the hedge funds
they know that that kind of actively
coordinating is going to is going to
result in some really serious
consequences from the sec
at the least of which is going to be
increased regulatory scrutiny um
but but the hedge funds are a very small
world
it is very tough to pursue a secret
hedge fund trading strategy pretty much
everybody figures out
what you're up to and so it's possible
that there
is going to be herd behavior related to
some of these hedge fund technique
techniques but i don't think there's
going to be any active coordination
like we saw in the case of the subreddit
group so what do you think the future
holds for
online trading communities like wall
street bets
you know i from what i've read about
wall street bets i think this will just
add to the this will add to the legend
right um
wall street wall street bets celebrated
people who made money but also people
had big losses so
in that sense it really was this kind of
interesting community um
i i think that there's a good chance
that they'll keep that kind of
that kind of camaraderie there although
i have i have
seen people starting to complain that
they're being invaded by by the bots and
by
other opportunistic uh companies trying
to generate business for their own
brokerages and things like that so
i i i honestly think that this will this
will in some ways serve to strengthen
that community
and it will inspire i think other
communities of small investors as well
i think one of the things that we've
learned here is that there is there
is still potential power in the small
investor and in some ways
i like to think of it as a as a back to
the future kind of moment
i mean this is this is literally the
type of kind of individual
trading that we we associate with stock
markets of long ago you know all the way
up to
maybe into the 20s but was really
largely gone after that
so do you think this situation overall
might lead to some new regulations
surrounding
short selling in general i can't think
of anything
i mean i think i as i said i i think
that there's
already a lot of there's actually a
sufficient amount of information about
short selling that's out there
i think what a lot of people don't
recognize is that short selling is
really hard and expensive
there are actually already regulations
that make it tough to short sell shares
you know the leading the leading
regulation of which is what they call
the uptick rule
you can't short sell a share of stock
unless the price is going up
you can't short it when it's going down
so you have to wait until the the price
move actually literally moves
up before you can actually short sell
the shares
in addition you have to post lots of
collateral to
the person you're borrowing the shares
from and and by the way
if the person you're borrowing the
shares from suddenly wants them back
you have to give them back immediately
and if your broker can't find somebody
else to borrow the shares from
you have to close out your short
position so there's a lot of extra risk
and a lot of extra expense with taking
on short positions and by the way that's
that's one of the main reasons why you
only see the big professional investors
use them
um and and i think that's part of the
reason why you get this kind of
the little guy is being kept out of this
it's really it's it's hard
it's really risky it's really expensive
to do shorting although i would say
it's a really really important function
of the markets i think that's another
part of the story that's being
overlooked here
that if it's not if it weren't for short
sellers we'd have even worse problems
with bubbles in the markets how do you
think the
renewed interest by this younger
demographic for
trading online is uh going to change the
market landscape
yeah i think that this this could bode
really well for the markets i think
getting more people
involved in trading and interested in
trading and interested in how the market
works can only be good for
our society and good for the economy um
i
i think um the democratization
of stock ownership and stock trading to
me is a really good thing
because again the more people we get
involved in this process
the more we understand it and the more
we realize it's both
it is important to the economy its
strengths and its limitations
so i'm i'm actually really optimistic
and hopeful that that examples like this
will get
a lot of people interested in trading
and hopefully interested in investing
i mean investing is just really a form
of trading where you where you
intend to hold the assets for a long
time i mean i'm not crazy about
i'm not crazy about day trading but i
don't think there's anything necessarily
wrong with it it's just not an
investment style that
i think is really good for most people
but but
to the extent that this gets young
people involved and says hey trading
owning shares and trading shares is
exciting it's rewarding
it's interesting um it's uh
something you can you can get involved
in as a hobby or even
even as a as a a side a side hustle or
even a career i think that's really good
and and i'm i'm kind of hopeful that
we'll get some results like that to get
to get more people uh just just to do
this as a hobby even
do you think this renewed popularity of
brokerage apps like
robinhood is going to change the market
landscape at all
yeah and and you know one of the things
i i mentioned in an earlier interview is
that that there's this what i call the
gamification
of trading so um you know robin hood has
been
has been criticized in some areas for
making its trading app kind of
look and feel like a little video game
and you know it's exciting to press that
buy button
and you know it's exciting to watch the
numbers uh spin around and all that kind
of good stuff and you know
and and i i think that's part of how you
attract
younger investors right people young
people are interested in gaming
uh and you know you make you make
trading more like a game you introduce
the social aspects
of games and gaming uh to it and and
again that's that's a that was a big
part i think of the attraction of this
uh
wall street vet subreddit you have this
community they respect they're kind of
both trading and being spectate
spectators for other people's trades
um that that social aspect of it is uh
is
is important it has been an important
part of a lot of stock market booms
and uh and and manias in the past
so what do you think the overall impact
might be on the economy from this
situation
i don't think it'll have a lot of impact
on the economy directly but like i said
i think
to the extent that it can get more
people interested and involved
in participating in the financial
markets yeah i think that's good
i think i think one of the things that
uh is distressing
about modern society is how little
people know
about financial markets and how they
work um and so that
you know in the aftermath of the of the
game stop
uh uh shares being halted and trading
people immediately start to think that
there's some some kind of uh
some some some bad activities or some
kind of influence peddling going on
when in fact you know it really was more
a function of this is how
we've designed the markets and set them
up to work if people understood that
better then
maybe we could have open discussions
about well how should we actually trade
shares
and maybe it isn't right to set up our
clearing and settlement system this way
or maybe it has
kind of weird consequences but we're not
having that conversation
um and it would mean it would be nice to
have more people to have that
understanding
and that confidence to participate in
the markets uh you know as
as kind of full-fledged to participants
rather than you know spectators or
people who say oh i could i could never
do that
so this one's a little out there but if
you could look into a crystal ball
and see what tomorrow's headlines will
be about the situation
what do you think they would read well
um
i i think i think that that
just the next big headline that could
come out of this is i i think
i think these uh the the the wall street
bet subreddit or
some some gang of individual investors
is going to find
something more like the gamestop thing
and then and we'll be back we'll be back
to that
before you know it um i i think
i think people are learning quite
rapidly
what where they can have this kind of an
influence and i think that
that some people are going to go out and
actively seek that and again it's
it's not just the money it's the whole
idea of being a part of a group that's
really kind of taking on the fat cats
and uh so i'm kind of hoping that they
go out they find the next game stop
or you know maybe they will find and
uncover um
you know a hidden gem maybe you know uh
um
that's that's always possible too all
right well that seems like a good spot
to wrap
so thanks again connell for chatting
with me today oh it's a great pleasure
it's fun to talk about and if you'd like
to learn more about how investing and
the stock market and the economy in
general works
be sure to check out all of connell
fullen camp's video series
on the great courses plus i put the link
in the description below
until next time this has been a look
inside current events with the great
[Music]
courses
[Music]
you